so what does the game of Sudoku have in
common with the game that entrepreneurs
play
so have you ever played the game of
Sudoku you know which game I'm talking
about where if you're on a plane you'll
see a lot of people playing on it or
you'll even see now these people playing
out on the iPad or their iPhones or they
grab these folders and they play and
they're just putting these numbers and
everybody says what is this game all
about the idea behind the game is where
you have nine numbers one through nine
in each box and each line can only have
one through nine you can't use two twice
and a line or two twice in a box and you
got to be able to fill the whole thing
up and it give you different levels some
of them are easy medium hard and you
have also diabolical which is supposed
to be the hardest one but what does
Sudoku have in common with what an
entrepreneur does on a daily basis well
I'll tell you if you ever play the game
of Sudoku what typically happens with
this game is you get to a point where
you're so stuck you can't look at the
numbers and say what goes in this year
so you go this way this way then you
look at the box nine what's missing then
you try to put them together two to two
you can only have two and you stuck and
then all of a sudden you get to Palmer
you say you know what forget I don't
play this anymore that's too hard this
diabolical thing is way too hard right
and you kind of just set it aside and
you maybe start another game where you
go to another game you see successful
entrepreneurs who end up becoming and
building what they build as their
companies that outlast them and does
very well for them is a lot of these
entrepreneurs have a tendency of not
stopping until they figure out the
number they are so obsessed about saying
I got to figure out this number because
they want to finish the game they
started and a lot of times a rookie or
an amateur entrepreneur will play the
game of being an entrepreneur it's
simply a game that's why you're playing
capitalism is a game free enterprise
free market is a game you got to play
and when you learn how to play the game
it could favor you but a lot of times
the reason why people don't win the game
is because every time they get to a
point they don't know the answer they
just give up right and they just say no
I'm gonna start a new game so I'm gonna
go travel realist and I'm gonna try
insurance I don't go try technology I'm
gonna go try juice I'm gonna go try this
I'm gonna go try them we'll go get my
you know a property casually I'm gonna
go again it's not the licenses it's not
the industry it's you playing the soduku
game of being an entrepreneur and every
time you get to a point you want to play
a new game
were an entrepreneur chooses an industry
right and understands the game of Sudoku
is gonna apply in any kind of a any kind
of venture you go into but you're gonna
need to come up with a game plan where
you've got to figure out and say okay
this is six this is three this is my one
box next box three box for box five
boxes and eventually you start looking
at everything you do as an entrepreneur
more like a game and you just need to go
out there and put the puzzle together
rather than saying oh my goodness I
don't know if I can do this or not let
me go into a whole different business so
my suggestion I challenge to you if
you've ever played soduku
finish the game get all the numbers
figured out if you want to play between
you and I rip the page out and go play
it when you're by yourself and try to
finish it up now if you do the same and
have the same mindset as an entrepreneur
some tells me that one thing you're
struggling with as an entrepreneur to
figure out you eventually figure out so
with that being said that's my message
in the week to them please be sure to
subscribe and share this video
you